[Music]
now um i'm curious uh if you're like me
i know that you know new york's in your
blood and today i'm walking to work and
i i pass they've put up the rockefeller
center christmas tree already it's 65
degrees outside the guys working on it
are in bathing suits uh
but i and i walked by and i thought you
know okay i feel like i'm maybe starting
to get into the christmas spirit i know
it's a little early how about you you
you know it's it's starting to feel that
way in new york a little bit yeah
there's a little a certain spring in the
step of most new yorkers around this
time of year and um
wow you really seem like you're in this
yeah a spring it's a little warm it's a
little warm to me right now but when it
gets cold and you have a nice wool scarf
on and a hat right and you see that tree
yeah a little tear oh you'll feel
christmassy
[Laughter]
you really tear up when you see the tree
dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's that kind of had that looked
at
that could be retinal damage of some
kind yeah well are you traditionally are
you someone that really gets into uh you
know like i want to decorate the home i
want to i do you know we we uh we have a
true you know very typical tree and
we're not crazy about it but
but we do definitely uh decorate and uh
my son now of course is very he knows
things are coming and uh and santa he
believes in i shouldn't say in case he's
but he believes in sansa of course he
should yes
[Laughter]
so he looks up the chimney now you know
just before bed he'll just be like
right
he doesn't whistle right he doesn't
whistle but he does that's nice that you
have a chimney uh because a lot of
people living in manhattan uh i like i
just gestured to our fake window
and i see yeah there you are
hello um
i bet james
no i i i i'm impressed because you have
chips
i live in an apartment there's no
chimney so there's a whole other myth
about santa comes through the microwave
oven you know
he climbs in the fire escape he can go
through fiber optic cable
he's downloaded and then yeah
it's weird yeah yeah but so he's excited
i think too literally it gets hard it
gets difficult even even with the
chimney if you get too
if you think about it too much it's
tough when santa get down and all that
you know what happens is you start to
ask ques you start answering initial
questions and then yeah i remembered at
that age asking a lot of questions and
then like well then you'd get like a
playstation or something for christmas
and you'd be like well how was this it
says right here it was made in china why
did and then it's like santa is
subcontractors you know
yep
very strange it's complicated your son's
getting into it your son's he is yeah is
it we i just occurred to me
walking around manhattan i see posters
for your movie yeah and uh i'm curious
if you've had what's it like when you're
out walking around with your son james
who is four i believe four you're
walking around with your boy james who's
four years old and you see your picture
does he connect that you're a well-known
person a little bit he's just starting
to you know i mean the whole world to
him is so strange anyway but that's just
an added layer of you know something
that he doesn't quite understand but he
um we were in central park uh yesterday
and we were leaving and there was a a
stand with um lots of uh postcards and
frames of new york you know scenes from
new york
and one was a little poster from the odd
couples is a picture of me and nathan
lane and he said oh papa that's you you
see there you are right there and i was
like yeah that's right look at that and
this woman was going through him and she
was
asked him some question he was like
he is him
and she said uh what and he was like
him is he
and she was like
okay you're crazy you know you're four
and i you are nuts what are they talking
about yeah you know four-year-old talk
and uh just went back to her other and
this is a nice little you know right but
i said i understand james wilkie i know
what you mean yeah i understood that i
got your back he is him he be he he yes
that man is he yes so he's what is what
can he do now that he's for what are his
i i i don't i don't know what a
four-year-old my kids are i have a a a
three-year-old daughter and a
one-year-old son so i'm curious like
what can they do it for they doing card
tricks can they crack a safe can they
hotwire a car
he's written two symphonies oh very good
very good yeah he's um
you know he it seems pretty much the
same he's a little more talkative
and uh he's very into role playing so he
puts on a spider-man or a superman or a
buzz lightyear outfit pretty much every
night when he gets home right he's like
uh spider-man please
you know starts taking off the shoes
when he gets in he's ready you bring the
spider-man costume yeah you put it on
him yeah
and then uh with spider-man uh recently
we realized when he's like i'm tired of
being spider-man i want to be peter
parker take my costume off
so peter parker has is uh basically
naked
naked is peter parker yeah that's very
strange spider-man yeah peter a naked
he's a naked guy running around the
earth i'm peter parker don't call me i'm
peter parker i'm peter parker
they're gonna work that into the next
movie i think